something we also need to talk about the
Broncos what are they missing what is
going on obviously losing 70 to 20 most
poor score games since 1966 it's
starting to become detrimental to the
team if we go to what garibald said
tired of losing man wow
I've been here for seven years and all
I've done is lost
and it's frustrating that's pain I think
people need to realize when you compete
at the highest level and it's just not
getting to where you want it to be that
hurts guys and I don't think people
realizing that there has to be a guy
over there that's going to step up and
say hey we gotta change this around and
it can't always be Russell Wilson
sometimes it gives a guy that everyone
knows gonna practice his butt off work
his butt off I know Pastor Chain's a guy
hey Pat I'm challenging you I know you
that dog up there get these boys
together brother